avez vous fait la maligne on vous a
préparé un petit texte particulier avec
une petite musique
mais voilà vous vous adaptez les nièces
non pas du tout vous présenter les
programmes là vous avez présenté pour un
documentaire sur le rap et après vous
vous laisser porter soyez convaincante
mais yahia dépareille des noms lalanne a
corrigé il faut juste le lire et le dire
avec conviction accord qui voit bien là
allez on y va
bonsoir mesdames bonsoir mes demoiselles
bonsoir messieurs salue le cas soc salue
les lionnes mais bien on va se caler
fait plus devant sa tv ce soir daniel va
vous faire plaisir car elle s'est fait
plaisir
tout d'abord un documentaire qui arrache
sa mère sur les regrettés de paktia cure
documentaire dédié de pâques c'est deux
packs de bière jamais vu entouré de leur
sauce sans oublier leurs gardes alors
cassure après on bifurquera sur mon
émission préférée puisque vous le savez
j'ai été la gagnante de la première élue
ce soir avec les stars ça sera la grande
finale qui opposera le moule de kim
kardashian à celui de nicki minaj
je vous attends les filles va falloir
venir chercher la couronne de mamans
voilées body boutique on se finir et
faire de beaux rêves cette nuit
direction le canal + pour le journal du
hard on voit que j'ai déjà en version
font commerce on pirate mais chut je
veux pas en finir en zonzon donc ce soir
vous aurez les bandes-annonces de fac
est plus rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]